your body wasn't designed to survive three Trump elections
but here are five really good reasons to remain hopeful
coming in at number one there is an unprecedented female voter turnout
everyone was saying this is a boy versus girl election
there's gonna be a huge gender gap
well as it turns out
women are outnumbering oh
women are outnumbering ha ha
it's a hard word women are outnumbering men by 10 points
and who are women more likely to support
Kamala Harris coming in at number two
the silver surge Pennsylvania voters
where I am talking to you from right now
especially our elders the seniors
have come out in droves to support Kamala Harris
even though as a demo they tend to lean Republican
grumpy old white man for the win
number Tres
No. 3 historical black voter turnout in Georgia
almost half of the state has already voted
which is good news for you guessed it
not the racist guy number quack cat
Pama Harris is closing in on Trump even in some deep red states like Texas
she is in fact
doing so well right now that she is positioned to have
the strongest democratic presidential performance
since 1992 lastly
remember Tom's Coachella for racist rally
well in Pennsylvania
there are half a million Puerto Ricans who will be voting
and reports are showing that uh
apparently uh
a lot of people don't like being called garbage
you know the comments are really racist
when Donald Trump acknowledges that they are racist
so consider this list your mental health toolbox